please pray with me may the Word of God
touch us body and soul and let us find
peace amen
so it's pretty clear today Jesus
instructs you are witnesses Peter
informs we are witnesses we are all
witnesses the greek word for witness
martes from our tour we know in english
by the word martyr and we've come to
know martyrdom a type of witnessing to
mean dying for one's belief but perhaps
a better understanding of witness or
martyrdom would be to inhabit one's
faith to live out one's belief in body
and in Seoul right up to death and right
on through death on Easter night this
year I gathered with friends some
Christian some non faith some other
faiths for a potluck dinner and when we
sat down the Christians were asked so
what's Easter about anyway what's this
living dying and raising of Jesus really
about what's it supposed to mean for us
here on earth in this fleshy messy world
and I think these are precisely the
questions we face in our gospel today
these are exactly the questions that we
wrestle with in this Easter season and
perhaps these are the central questions
we as in Easter people are meant to be
witnesses to in this messy fleshy world
what's with this living dying and
raising of Jesus what's it supposed to
mean for us here on earth in our messy
fleshy lives the disciples are wrestling
with these exact questions when Jesus
appears giving some pretty pretty big
clues Jesus says
have you anything here to eat see that I
have flesh and bones look at my hands
and my feet peace be with you we ask
what's it's all supposed to mean for us
here in our messy fleshy lives and the
disciples asked these questions to Jesus
today tells us and shows us even this
whole risen it has everything to do with
bodies this whole risen bit has
everything to do with the messy fleshy
stuff of creation this might be hard for
some of us to wrestle with even here on
this fleshy wet moist earth day and it
definitely would have been hard to
imagine pretty shocking frightening
we're told even for Jesus's disciples
community who in their day viewed bodies
as scary freakish porous leaky things
leaking all over one another so for
Jesus's friends who had gone to the tomb
and found Jesus's poorest leaky body
missing for Jesus's friends who had
watched Jesus's body imprisoned tortured
and killed by the Roman authorities for
these witnesses that the Risen Jesus
arrives in risen body asking have you
anything here to eat this would have
been mind-blowing disturbing weird to
eat is one of the most basic most bodily
things we do something that leads to
another basic very messy bodily thing
mind-blowing disturbing scary weird
maybe for us too but perhaps it was also
reassuring for eating and not just
eating but the rituals around
the mule around eating then as now is at
the heart of gathered communities here
in our church feasting on the word and
bread and body are certainly the center
of our life but isn't eating at the
heart of our families and communities
outside of the church as well I don't
know about you but one of the first
things I do when I go home to my parents
place or my sister's place as I say is
there anything here to eat after
greeting them of course and they do that
to me something basic something central
and i know i look forward to favorite
family dishes or special holiday dishes
maybe we all do like asturiens ham and
grit grits on Easter or the rack of lamb
and all I had at my potluck Easter
dinner the broiled fish would have been
a nice treat and a taste of home for
those gathered disciples in Jerusalem
and specially those fishermen far away
from the sea it may be some of you share
this with me but it's like an unwritten
rule in my family at the big family
gatherings that irregardless of
available space in other parts of the
home we will spend most of our time in
the kitchen before meals after meals
between meals we cram as many bodies
together as possible talking chattering
preparing cooking cleaning laughing
breathing healthy broken young old
bodies leaning and hugging up on one
another fun conversations serious
conversations we get to the heart of
things gathered there around our rituals
of eating and the Risen Jesus gets to
the heart of things to those
disbelieving chattering wandering joyful
sad fearful bodies gathered around Jesus
and to us believing wandering fearful
joyful sad bodies gathered here today
feasting on the word the risen Lord gets
to the heart of things see that I am
flesh and bones that the god of glory
had been flesh and bones the great
mystery of
incarnation Christ made man the
disciples had accepted this but that the
risen Lord the Messiah who was meant to
usher in a whole new age and kingdom of
God who perhaps they had expected to
come and fire and storm the big and
booming Almighty God our risen Lord that
he would appear in flesh and bone glory
in flesh and bones unbelievable in our
day and age perhaps we've gotten a bit
more knowledgeable about our fleshly
lives but are we truly any more
comfortable with the messy fleshiness of
bodies than Jesus's disciples would have
been are we truly and any more ready to
accept our risen Lord and bodied form I
certainly feel pretty glad and ready and
able to glorify the body when I'm
feeling fit and strong out on the soccer
field weaving the ball through players
sitting next to my best friend laughing
kissing someone with whom I'm in a
committed relationship peacefully
marching with thousands for immigration
rights fists clenched chanting si se
puede or sitting in a crowded room with
youth planning to how to affect change
in their community or whistling back and
forth with the birds and the forests as
a hike through the woods or sharing an
aha moment poring over a book or crammed
in that kitchen with my cousins aunts
and uncles with full stomach or gathered
here in this beloved Church oh my body
sang Walt Whitman in his poem I sing the
body electric oh my body I believe the
likes of you are to stand or fall with
the likes of my soul and so we too can
sing to our bodies beautiful multi
shaped multi formed multicolored multi
cultured bodies created by God look
beautiful bodies beautiful flesh and
bone glorious indeed but what about when
we consider brokenness in our bodies do
we find glory in the body then perhaps
you like I find myself responding then
more like Jesus's disciples community
disbelieving and fearful when we inhabit
and consider body struck by illness pain
or addiction or bodies blown apart in
war or bodies tortured for their belief
race or ethnicity perhaps you find
yourself like me and Jesus's disciples s
believing and afraid when we consider
bodies of our departed loved ones like
the beloved friend and child who died
here on Yale's campus last week Zach
blunt or when we inhabit or consider
bodies riddled by grief perhaps you like
I find myself more find yourselves more
like Jesus disciple community
disbelieving and fearful when we inhabit
or consider women's bodies violently
maligned and hyper sexualized in today's
media or hungry bodies in prison bodies
bodies scarred by trauma perhaps you
like I find myself responding more like
Jesus's disciples community disbelieving
and fearful when we consider bodies
misused self abusing self-hating bodies
overindulging bodies violent bodies
fleeing bodies terrified discipled
bodies perhaps you like how i find
myself find yourselves responding more
like Jesus disciple community
disbelieving and fearful when you
consider this earth scarred body raised
forests polluted waters drill ruined
hands body's feeling broken bodies
feeling alone when we consider and
inhabit these broken bodies what then of
our flesh and bones what then of this
messy fleshy existence what glory then
Jesus says look at my hands and feet and
in this messy fleshy and body world of
ours it's so easy and so natural to want
to look away like the disciples to want
to look for our risen Lord up in the
heavens and mountaintops for fire and
thunderstorms and chariots but Jesus is
here before us today saying I'm right
here look at my hands and my feet hands
and feet scarred like ours by messy
fleshy stuff pierced as they hung on a
cross hands that healed and comforted
and lived among the suffering poor and
cast out feat that walked with and
journeyed in this lifetime hands and
feet that journey with and a company in
life and in death look at my hands and
feet hands and feet of friendship hands
that hold us and feet that walk with us
in our broken messy fleshy bodies in
this messy fleshy life of ours and hands
that hold us and feet that walk with us
in the world to come look at my hands
and feet risen hands and risen feet that
promise us and our brokenness in our
suffering we will be transformed the
body of our risen Lord is a risen body a
transformed body that promises we too
and all of creation will be transformed
we will be raised up
there is a life to calm of healing and
wholeness justice and freedom peace and
happiness repentance and forgiveness
we're living and dead are joined
together as a communion of saints there
is a risen life in Christ that
encapsulates and transforms all of us
even and maybe especially the messy bits
where the entirety of our beings our
relationships our communities our
nation's where the entirety of God's
earth its trees and water and mountains
is raised and transformed look at my
hands and my feet we will be raised up
not from but in this messy fleshy life
Stephen Cooper rights to insist on the
reality of the resurrected body is to
demand that we accept our present
reality as the place where
transformations of ultimate significance
take place friends look at the hands and
feet of the mystical body of the risen
Christ of which by which and through
which we and our fleshiness are apart
how beautiful how glorious are the hands
and feet of Christ and look around again
we are the hands and feet of Christ look
at my hands in my feet we are the hands
and feet of Christ when we accompany one
another and softener suffering when we
walk in solidarity with the least of
those when we transform systems and
injustice when we seek compassion and
peace look at my hands and feet we are
the hands and feet of Christ when we
care for the planet its resources its
waters its lands when we resist greed
and over consumption when we search for
solutions to global inequality look at
my hands and feet we cannot look away
a-and nor would we want to we are
Christ's hands and feet messy but
glorious indeed a few days ago I went
for a hike something I like to do a lot
in mountains of sorts as you can call
mountains in Connecticut Hills really
and there is this moment this one
blessed moment where the Sun was shining
down the stream was trickling the
Cardinals were calling the turkeys were
flapping the sparrows were singing and
this is literally bugs buzzing frogs
croaking tiny leaves just being bloomed
rustling in the wind blowing gently
against my skin alone but never less
alone in God's glorious created world
this moment I felt truly a part of the
one body of Christ and I thought this is
peace oh that I could stay here all my
days the same piece that I experienced
in worship Nevermore one with Christ as
one body worshiping at the beautiful
feet of Christ oh that we could stay
here all our days but christ's peace
which inhabits us body and soul and
transforms us and brings us into the one
body christ's peace is a participatory
peace the prophet Isaiah exclaims how
beautiful upon the mountains are the
feet of the messenger who announces
peace who brings good news who announces
salvation who says to Zion your God
reigns how beautiful indeed yet Jesus
announces peace not in fire or storm or
heaven not from the mountaintops but in
the midst of this fleshy messy world
beautiful indeed Jesus proclaims peace
be with you and the transform disciples
go out into the messy fleshy world they
must leave Jerusalem
we proclaim Christ peace with one
another shake hands and our fleshy
existence but we too are transformed by
this participatory peace we must go out
into the messy fleshy world we must
leave our sanctuary christ's peace which
announces and realizes the kingdom of
god our new earth come in the fleshy
earthy messy stuff of this world
christ's peace is meant to be lived in
the fleshy earthy messy stuff of this
world christ's peace invites our
participation in the healing body of
christ our participation in a cloud of
witnesses our participation in the
transformation of the entire fleshy
earthy messy world that's already taking
place christ's peace which surpasses all
understanding is a glimpse on this messy
fleshy earth of eternal life to come
Christ peace is nothing short of a
co-creating birth announcement in Christ
through Christ with Christ by Christ we
are a part of the newer and new life
happening here in our messy fleshy world
in Christ through Christ with Christ and
by Christ who lived died and rose all
creation and all of us are born anew we
and our messy bodies are the beautiful
hands and feet of Christ we are
witnesses to these things we are
witnesses in Christ through Christ with
Christ and by Christ and so let us
witness in body and soul to the Peace of
Christ in this messy earthly world in
life right up to death and right on perv